as House of the Dragon in rings of power
battle it out for Fantasy dominance I'm
just hitting here like give me another I
don't care in the most action-packed
episode yet the battle for the
stepstones comes to an end and Ranier is
dodging marriage proposals like Neo in
The Matrix this is a non-spoiler video
that takes a deep dive into the lore
world and characters and consider liking
and subscribing as I do come out with a
next episode spoiler video usually every
Monday but for now let's get into it a
seahorse Banner the emblem of house
Valerian Burns somewhere in these step
stones and I can't begin to stress just
how strategically important these
islands are to the realm these
stepstones are basically a bridge
between the nine free cities of essos to
the East and Dorne in the west now at
this time in Westeros history Dorne is
not formally a part of the Seven
Kingdoms you might recall from episode 2
that sir Kristen Cole saw battle against
the dornish well stationed in the
dornish marshes so if these steps to
zones were to fall to the triarchy there
would be nothing stopping them from
establishing an alliance with Dorne and
controlling one of the most vital sea
corridors in the world the triarchy
seems to be enjoying their Spoils of War
we'll later hear how unsuccessful Damon
and corliss's campaign has been they
opted to fight kragistrahar without the
backing of the king and making things
considerably more difficult we'll see a
soldier of house Valerian curse this
mirish Prince Admiral who lives up to
his name of crab feeder the soldier
refers to kragus as a betrayer and that
his mother was a horror and father a
bastard however there's no mention of
this in the book in fact there's no
mention of what he looks like at all so
this whole Phantom of the Opera
aesthetic is of the show's own making
the triarchy's pillaging is put on hold
when Prince Damon arrives on his dragon
caraxis and I love how this Soldier
thought Damon was coming to save him but
gets completely crushed demon really has
no regard for his men at the Forefront
of his mind is Victory and we'll see
this play out to an even larger extent
near the end of the episode now you
might be asking yourself what are these
archers doing firing at caraxis their
arrows wouldn't even be able to
penetrate its iron-like scales they're
actually trying to shoot Daemon for it's
thought that if you kill the rider the
dragon becomes much like a boat without
a Rudder and as demon taunts crab feeder
to reveal himself he is shot but what's
more interesting here is the dragon's
reaction it's almost as if the dragon
got shot too it bellows in pain and
flies off in Retreat not much is known
about the connection between dragon and
dragon rider in fact the book even says
this we shall not pretend to have any
understanding of the bond between dragon
and Dragon Rider only hinting that quote
some will claim that the bond between a
dragon and Dragon Rider runs so deep
that the Beast shares his master's loves
and hates what this scene seems to
suggest is that a dragon can feel its
Master's pain which is some something
that will undoubtedly come into play
later in the season far from the
battlefields of the stepstones we make
our way back to King's Landing where
roughly two years have passed since the
events of episode 2. King viserys has
married Allison's Hightower and now has
a son aegon II named after the first
king of Westeros and also the man who
foreshadowed the coming of The Long
Winter According to viserys fun fact
Damon did not attend his brother's
wedding Otto hightower's older brother
Lord Hobart Hightower pressures the hand
of the king to steer viserys toward
naming aegon II heir to the throne this
is quite interesting considering in
episode 1 Lord Hobart declared his
fealty to viserys and his chosen
successor rhaenyra last episode The King
also reiterated to his daughter that
even if he were to have a male son she
would still be his Heir so a lot of the
conflict the king faces in this episode
is whether or not to go back on his word
and name aegon as his new Heir we get
our first look at Island Lannister an
ancestor of Cersei Jaime in Tyrion from
Game of Thrones he informs the king that
crab feeder has dug in for a Siege on
Bloodstone the largest of the islands
that compose the step Stones The King
does not want to hear of this especially
on his son's name day and it appears
some of the other Lords make note of
this indecision Alison can be seen
pregnant again so I guess taking an
interest in your husband's toy model
hobby has really paid off for her Lionel
strong the king's master of laws informs
viserys that things are ready for him to
make his way to the Kingswood where he
is to be expected by Lord Jason
Lannister the twin brother of Thailand
although we never see this scene in the
show this is a hint of the king testing
out potential matches for his daughter
the two are interrupted by Thailand who
once again outlines the gravity of the
situation in the stepstones with the
crab feeder and his men dug into the
cave system on Bloodstone they have
become impervious to dragon attacks now
Damon cell swords are leaving in droves
and questioning his command the king
however won't intervene it would make
the crown appear weak if he were to
support his brother who started this war
in the first place well I guess Ed
Sheeran wasn't available for this part
as a troubadour entertains rhaenyra she
is clearly not interested in being at
her half-brothers party the Troubadour
sings of a woman who fled with her ships
and her people which is likely a song
about Princess nymeria the same princess
Allison tested renera on in episode 1.
it's a nice little callback as that
scene also took place right by this
werewood tree Allison has come to inform
an era that the Royal Hunt is ready to
depart but rhaenyra doesn't want to go
at all even though it's been two years
renera still holds a lot of resentment
for her former best friend who withheld
her relationship with her father the way
they show this power dynamic between
these two is fantastic with Allison
telling the singer to leave and renira
wanting him to stay Alison has a higher
rank being the queen thus he listens to
her so it's just more salt in the wound
for rhaenyra on a bumpy carriage ride
which you know can't be good for that
baby visiris says renera will one day
make him a proud grandsire but we know
from episode 1 that Ranier would prefer
to be a knight than a mother at every
turn renera shuns her father he like
Alison has betrayed her maybe just a
coincidence but there's a nice cup
behind raniera she is the cup Bearer
after all I absolutely love this wide
shot of the Kingswood with King's
Landing in the background the Royal
Carriage arrives and we get our first
shot of Loris and Harwin strong the sons
of Master of laws Lionel strong Loris
walks with a cane because he was born
with Twisted legs both of these men will
play large roles in the events to come
master of kissing ass Lord Hobart
Hightower cheers the new Prince as
raniera sits alone in the carriage
having to listen to all the Lords of the
land cheer on her step bro and I thought
vacations with my parents were bad
Rainier is Solitude is further expressed
visually as she enters the Royal tent
and no one pays her any attention except
of course Jason Lannister who shares a
look with the King for renera the king
discussing her marriage behind her back
is yet another betrayal as Allison
enjoys a glass of wine while pregnant it
was a different time the ladies of the
Court discussed the latest gossip
chiefly the Abduction of Lady Joanna
Swann who was sold to a pillowhouse in
Fire and Blood we actually hear what
happened to her her ship was captured by
the triarchy and quote amongst those
enslaved was Lady Joanna Swann a 15 year
old niece of the Lord of stonehelm when
her infamously definitely not going to
say that word Uncle refused to pay the
ransom she was sold to a pillowhouse
she'll later climb up the ranks and
become the most celebrated courtesan in
lease taking the name Black Swan
essentially becoming the ruler of that
free City in all but name so it'll be
interesting if we'll see her in future
episodes or Seasons Lars joins the women
stating that his leg really does not
suit being with the men for the hunt in
reality this might be a calculated move
having a pulse on the latest gossip of
the realm could be a value for someone
looking to climb the ranks some serious
shade is thrown by rhaenyra bite lady
redwin never explicitly stated but she
is likely related to the former Lord
commander of the kingsguard Ryan redwin
who we learned passed away last episode
which would actually mean two years ago
even though some of these women openly
questioned why renero was chosen as Heir
instead of Damon it's Alison who sticks
up for her friends stating the princess
was more suited to the right I really do
believe that Allison at least in this
point in time is sincere in trying to
mend their friendship Jason Lannister
puts the moves on renera with about as
much grace as I did with my high school
Crush just swap out the lannis port wine
with Bacardi Breezer and it's spot on
Jason has definitely put the cart before
the horse telling raniera how beautiful
casterly rock is the home to House
Lannister because there's nothing that
gets a girl going more than bragging
about the size of your rock when renera
finds out this was all a ruse and Lord
Jason was trying to get his way into her
Dragon pit she storms off to her father
who we find has been Fielding marriage
proposals for some time she does not
want to marry but the king states that
even he is not above tradition and Duty
their argument is seen by everyone at
court and auto interrupts before it gets
further out of hand by stating a white
stag was spotted in the Kingswood if the
king were to kill it it would be a
tremendous sign by the gods especially
on a hunt meant to celebrate the new
Prince a furious rhaenyra Ventures off
into the Wilds her faithful protector
sir Kristen Cole in quick Pursuit sir
Kristen gives raniera the opportunity to
vent her frustrations she believes she
was meant to be more than the wife to a
lord at casterly Rock even though she
may be a princess she feels dutyless sir
Kristen and raniera aren't too different
they both feel like they've had no say
in their lives however it's sir
Christian who reminds renera that she
has shaped people's lives it was her who
allowed him to become a member of the
kingsguard the highest honor any member
of the House coal has ever achieved he's
even had his name put in the white book
A two foot tall book filled with
thousands of pages depicting the great
Deeds of the members of the kingsguard
the king and his men are hot on the
trail of this white heart before dragons
the white heart was the main symbol of
royalty so what better way the gods can
show their favor than by having one
killed and is it just me or did he
actually pick that up Jason the
teacher's pet has a spear specially
fashion for this occasion one that was
forged in the golden Gallery the
Lannisters Hall of treasures at casterly
Rock he has come to ask for raniera's
hand proclaiming that she will feel
quite comfortable for her loss in
station but the king doesn't know what
Jason means by this renera will be Queen
one day and Jason has mistakenly
presumed that young aegon will supplant
her this proves a costly error for Jason
when the king reminds him and those
watching that he he didn't name renira
his successor on a whim also love the
detail of the dragon head on the back of
viserys's seat here to offer some
alternative suggestions are Otto
Hightower and Lionel strong suggesting
that the Young Prince aegon a suitable
match for renera this isn't uncommon in
the Targaryen family viserys's parents
Balon and Alyssa were brother and sister
and so were his grandparents jaharas and
alisane Lionel also offers another match
which the king first thinks is Lionel's
own son Harwin break bones considered
the strongest man in the Seven Kingdoms
but it's actually rhaenice and corliss's
eldest son Leonor Valerian it's arguably
the most practical match the valerians
are a Noble House extremely affluent and
a match would do well to mend the
relationship between Targaryen and
Valerian after the king chose not to Wed
their daughter Elena but if Ranier is to
wedling or he must first survive the
fighting in the stepsons I also want to
make quick mention that we haven't
really seen if the king's sickness has
gotten any worse we saw both his back
and fingers suffer from a mysterious
incurable ailment so expect that to make
a return in future episodes rhaenyra and
Kristen camp for the night where renera
asks if the realm will ever accept her
as Queen she's probably thinking about
what her aunt said last episode that men
would rather see the realm put to the
torch than see a woman sit on the throne
Kristen doesn't have the best response
saying that the realm will be forced to
accept her but before the conversation
can continue they're attacked by a wild
boar and Rainier just lets out all this
pent-up rage killing it years of
betrayal frustration and anger poured
into every stroke of her blade a drunk
King viserys lemons his current
predicament he's being pressured from
all sides to name aegon as Heir which
would mean spurning his daughter for the
king so wanted his son he became
obsessed with it believing this
obsession is what would eventually kill
his dearest Emma he thought naming
renera as Heir was the right thing to do
after all he didn't think he'd remarry
and have a son no less so maybe his
dream of having a boy wearing the crown
of King aegon the same dream he told to
Emma wasn't Emma's child but Allison's a
horn blows announcing that the hunt has
found a large stag but not the white one
they hoped for in a gut-wrenching scene
the King has to stab the Beast multiple
times before it dies a bad Omen if you
ask me this is juxtaposed to Rainier and
Kristen who actually come across this
white stag Kristen is ready to slay the
beast but renera tells him not to if the
king's encounter was a bad Omen this
surely was a good one a sign from the
gods that rhaenyra is favored and I love
it when Rainier walks back into camp
with this giant boar they killed and
everyone's watching her like
how dare she Auto the ever-loving father
that he is has come to talk shop with
the queen he's been pressured by his
brother to sway the king in naming aegon
air and what better way to do that than
by manipulating your daughter he
appeases to her sense of Peace stating
that if rhaenyra were to step over aegon
being King the realm would tear itself
apart but then again the king did name
her as successor to which equips that
that was before aegon was born he
instructs his daughter to sway the king
toward reason and name aegon his Heir
the queen interrupts The Hungover King
who's in the middle of reading a letter
from vamon Valerian Corliss valerian's
younger brother this is a departure from
the book in which vemond is corliss's
nephew not brother it seems Corliss and
Damon are losing badly and vaymond is
pleading for Aid if the king does send
Aid how does this look to the rest of
the realm giving troops to two
malcontents the queen wisely distills
the question of intercession down to
this is it better that crab feeder
thrives or is vanquished and that helps
the king make his decision to help the
two briefly discuss rhaenyra where the
queen comments that renewer must feel
like she's given the choice on whom to
marry for it to work but that's easier
said than done the King has sent a
messenger to dwarf Stone one of these
smaller Islands Corliss and Damon used
to launch their Siege of Bloodstone in
this letter the King has decided to
offer aid but that Aid will take some
time in order to get there Rainier sits
with her father coincidentally in the
chair reserved for the hand of the king
she can't help but feel like a pawn just
a bargaining chip her father can use to
sell for a fleet of ships or a mountain
stronghold Ranier even says that the
Lords of the realm gather to Feast on
the bones of her carcass which is pretty
much what viserys said after the death
of his wife and son visiris knows what
it's like to be in rhaenyra's position
Emma was a fine choice for him because
she was an Aaron of the veil and they
had an army which would rival that of
the north however in this case it worked
for for the king as he ended up falling
in love with her you know when he's not
cutting babies out of her so the king
wanting to see rhaenyra contented gives
her the choice on who to marry hoping
that her choice will strengthen her
claim to the throne and Shore up her
secession and she seems pretty happy
with this decision the scene ends with a
promise on her mother's memory that she
will not be supplanted it seems the
wavering he was having a few nights ago
has subsided and he is firmly stuck by
his choice the Final Act of the episode
revolves around the siege of Bloodstone
and it is not going well even though we
can see Damon flying around on caraxis
the crap feeder and his forces merely
Retreat into the caves whenever the
dragon comes near essentially making
them useless with food and men running
low and help weeks away something must
be done or defeat is inevitable vaiman
believes the problem is Damon going so
far as to say if the king won't even
help him why should they but Corliss
quickly quiets his brother he won't have
any Mutiny here as demon arrives so too
does the king's a messenger giving demon
word that his brother is to ride with 10
ships and 2 000 men for Damon this is
the worst possible news the whole point
of him and his campaign in the
stepstones was to prove himself without
the help of his brother that's why he
takes his rage out on the messenger and
volunteers himself as bait to lure the
triarchy forces from their caves Damon
arrives alone on Bloodstone offering a
white flag of surrender and his sword
Dark sister as a sign of defeat but
kragistrahar isn't stupid he checks the
skies for dragons and sends only a few
men at a time to retrieve the prince the
whole thing is a wildly dangerous dare
say heroic aroos in order to get crab
feeder's men out of their holes and it
actually works Damon goes on a rampage
but is soon shot down by multiple arrows
pinned against the worn out Hull of a
wrecked ship sensing the Rogue Prince is
on his last legs the crab feeder sends
out the last of his men which will prove
to be a fatal Mr stake the diversion has
allowed corliss's men to ride ashore and
more importantly the dragon sea smoke to
make quick work of the enemy surrounding
Damon sea smoke is now the Third Dragon
we've been introduced to thus far only
14 more to go he's written by Lenor
Valerian who you'll recall has Targaryen
blood being the son of renice from this
point it basically becomes a crispy
bloodbath and under the combined
pressure of the Valerian forces and a
dragon the triarchy forces are defeated
Damon wants crab feeder's head and
pursues him into the caves we don't
actually see them fight but honestly I
was okay with that we just got this
beautiful action sequence and I was fine
with not seeing them duke it out it also
lines up with a book that simply states
crab feeder was slain by Damon in
single-handed combat with his sword Dark
sister the only difference was that he
was beheaded I also love this shot of
Damon next to this treasure as he
himself holds on to his treasure the
Torso of crab feeder the episode ends on
Damon successfully reading the
stepstones of crab feeder and doing so
without the help of his brother that is
it for this episode I hope you'll Stick
Around And subscribe since I'll be doing
a spoiler video for episode 4 and I also
have videos on the rings of power show
if you want to Deep dive into that lore
thanks for watching everyone for more
bad takes you can follow me on Twitter
and Instagram at thinkstory YT until
next time remember and obvious of the
month late lady red wine waiting cake